hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we just
finished getting the singularity core
Kendra was ungrateful but it's okay it's
a thankless job I don't need thanks
whatever it would be nice
tyreel more goodies and more goodies in
here I should probably be more worried
that the whole ship is exploding around
me but come on do I worry about anything
is hammy over here I've been trying to
reach her mic on without okay y'all the
single area called that's our ticket out
of here
oh hey that's my line
oh oh oh I don't look good
hammy hammy you alright
yeah dad
sorry buddy all right I'm just gonna
back away slowly oh oh what that you
wanna know nope that's a day
I'm the shoulder all that bad I feel
good
humble enough you huddling up that'll do
you any good
we throw his old gun at you Oh double
gunning it huh nope not today
ah get away
oh man you are tough
come on get it no no no I uh stasis his
yeah
Oh get some Oh knock your queen off yeah
you're so worried about her poor guy
what a way to go I guess
sorry buddy you're the only corpse that
I would ever trust that's true um I
guess we need to get out of here cuz old
ships exploding whatever I laugh in the
face of danger
oh god Tara I've only got a stronger
failure to change okay don't care
does this face look like it cares
oh it's real exciting all the ships
exploding morning catastrophic failure
you can take uh-huh you wait the vessel
is yeah that's that's real nice buddy
okay don't trust you
you're not hammy yes during a fire it's
always best to take the end of it
catastrophic failure fuel injection
whoopee-doo buddy we're all gonna die in
a big fire wall fireball but whatever
fire wall fire wall is the unheard
sequel to Wonderwall contain evacuate
the much more exciting it's a death
metal song
come on what the hell morning I'll go
this way of course lotion
yeah oh man give me something exciting
yeah that seems about right
I'll just meander my way I should just
jump down to the planet from here I'm
just so tough whoa hello boom bang II
can I see what's going on boo me back oh
look it's so pretty oh wow look it's
like fireworks all right guy exiting
zero-gravity yep thank you back to the
nice computer lady thank you ma'am
and thank you for not yet going crazy
and telling me stuff that's supposed to
degrade me make me feel bad about myself
haha
get over here twitchy how'd you get over
here stop twitching you what is wrong
with your head
wha Oh your like whole top of your heads
gone you're just messed up bro you is
messed up now to see what I don't think
I have much time mode but maybe
something odd diamond semiconductor holy
crap 25 how is it yeah give me that
money
dolla dolla bill y'all more power nodes
why not ah there another level of suit I
can get nice pose buddy nice pose mmm
now what can I upgrade
I don't really know maybe the rest of my
stasis module why not
hardly use stasis enough anyway what
else we got
Kinesis alright sure I got nothing
better to use it on air I don't need air
when he's there oh I could upgrade my
plasma cutter didn't think about that
but whatever well uh it wouldn't be the
pulse rifle challenge if I tried to
upgrade and use the plasma cutter pistol
gun Arai chapter 9 chapter 9 completed
dead on arrival bare y'all alright I'm
doing good feel like I'm going through
this story quicker now maybe I am maybe
I'm just that good who knows
end of days where am I going now crew
deck why would a shuttle be on the crew
deck anyway doesn't in the crew deck
like where the people live
I mean that's just that's just me guess
me guess that's me guess lots o you're
doing you're gonna get it now but
located the shuttle Hammond found uh-huh
oh poor family no good that shuttles
brain dead
oh and remove the navigation cards kind
nose why there's three of them scattered
around the deck of course their location
free cards scattered around your level
the doors from here so you'll need a
crew key if you can find us parts I
think we can get that shuttle
operational again yeah sounds just about
right okay this looks weird bunch of
dead people yeah I knocked your candle
over what do you think of that dead
people huh sure yeah
Oh everyone's gonna get now chair boom
oh yeah what do you feel about that
knocked your leg off chair tables get
out here sure no chair being called into
action
did these these guys shoot themselves or
did someone come by and shoot them a
chair to the face
uh-uh hear voices in my head I'm going
crazy someone singing twinkle twinkle
little star ah what the heck yeah took
one look at me and ran away pass right
and what's going on here
this looks messed up zero-g basketball
yeah all locked was the point of that
I even have them yeah oh yeah huh y'all
know go get it I know where I saw store
levels I have a suit if you couldn't see
it it was a level 5 suit that I just
pick up so yeah of course I'm gonna go
get it what the heck else am I gonna do
there we go oh oh oh yeah Oh level 5
suit 60,000 oh that's what I get for
buying that one extra round of pulse
rifles pills bullets yeah never Bob I
really don't know what those suits do
besides look better and give me more
inventory space that's pretty much all I
care about the more inventory
I guess do they give more like more
defense because there are more plates I
don't know yeah look at me oh why didn't
they just give this to me when they
shipped us out but I don't know what's
the point of a engineer having more
armor I don't know but I'm happy yeah
Oh down to 2,000 credits now okay oh I'm
looking burly that's how I like my men
big and burly take that any way you want
I'm gonna stop talking I'm just gonna
stop talking oh what's that
it's time gobbledygook Heba flab amor ba
che Bello
I'm phenomena isn't it I'm fluent in
crap Inez Z ball rules step on a lighted
platform and start the game jump to as
many scoring platforms as possible to
increase your score multiplier then use
your Kinesis module to grab the ball and
shoot it into the app to active basket
before the shot timer runs out beating
ynx level will opens a locker with a
reward inside I can actually play zero
gravity basketball why no way
first there was a shooting gallery and
then this but what what oh man what the
heck well
hey black ones just dumped kind of try
yes get know
got it Hey who did that all right where
where they are
ow stop it now hurt bad baby bad baby
bad baby those are tough I took a lot of
juice bullet juice all right how do i I
want to play how do I start
oh okay that's kinky I grab it with my
Kinesis shoot it in bingo two points
bingo three points how did I get two
points before why do I hear people bingo
wait is there some rule that I ignored
act
no no get I swear to goodness
where'd you go pretty go there
ah bingo
hey oh yeah everybody cheer for me funk
Oh like it ain't no thing
funk oh yeah nothing nothing better in a
horror game than some basketball ha ha
some zero-g basketball the multiplier
thing goes up I don't know okay they're
like lighted lit up places they're lit
up hang on let me see let me see here
I go to these okay that did something ah
ah
where's the ball where's the ball there
it is no come here
do that and then the multipliers at
three ah there we go so I just got a hop
to the UM the lit panels then shoot ah I
know you tricks ah this would be a weird
disorienting sport
there are only three lip panels looks
like it
bunk up make it in yeah
high score 32 not bad not bad man that
took a while though so I think that's
the only round I'm gonna do hey there we
go yeah go me everybody pat me on the
back all right okay that's it ah can't
scare me unscareable high get stomped
license to stop do nothing
stop is like the wimpiest thing in the
world huh
I heard something up all right whatever
they don't man okay moving on to where
of the heck I needed to go which is this
way hmm oh there's a box over there that
I forgot to get by the chair oh wait a
comfort no no you're not gonna infect
all these bodies no not no no no yeah no
you you die you go ahead you dad that's
right what I heard that I heard some
that there
Oh Punk miss wagon events there Isaac
alright I gotta cut it here but thank
you guys so much for watching as always
I do appreciate and I will see you in
the next part but I